ciao a tutti io sono beatrice cascone ho
24 anni e sono appassionata di spazio
oggi sono qui per mettere in dubbio
alcune delle mie più grandi certezze
nel vostro tempo libero e sono sicura
che molto poco sulle mie
vi sarete imbattuti in magari giovani
spaziali oggi parleremo di chi sono da
dove vengono
dove li troviamo
e perché proprio spaziali
queste sono due frasi due citazioni la
prima del giornale la provincia del 12
aprile 1961
la quale cita il primo astronauta ha
volato intorno alla terra
oppure la seconda questo è un piccolo
passo per l'uomo ma un balzo gigantesco
per l'umanità
detta da neil armstrong quando mise
piede per la prima volta sul territorio
in un'area
per alcuni queste frasi sono molto
banali quante volte nella vostra storia
sentito parlare di neymar strong
dell'atterraggio lunario degli stati
uniti d'america
tanto che per alcuni
queste frasi sono false
meglio fake news
per comprenderla al meglio però dovremmo
fare un passo indietro
andare alla ricerca
della storia spaziale
esiste anche una storia spaziale
e quindi
andremo a parlare
dell'inizio della storia però voglio
farvi
conoscere un po più di me perché sono
appassionata di spazio questo è un cielo
stellare
quando avevo tre anni
mia nonna si chiamava stella
le chiese un giorno il suo significato
il significato del suo nome perché non
era francesca perché non si chiamava
lucia
fabrica stella lei non mi rispose mai mi
dica va sempre con la mano quel cielo
stellato
e mi diceva che arrivava da lì
come a tre anni ancora oggi col mio
nasino all'insù
cerco di
ritrovarla lì dentro
e con la manina a tre anni cercavo di
prenderle quelle stelle cercavo di farle
mie dicevo ci devo arrivare
ancora oggi lo faccio lo nascondo
quando post
quell'universo era così lontano per me
che una bambina di tre anni
ci spera ci prova ci crede oggi da 24 lo
faccio ancora
per me quell'universo oggi è presente
ma soprattutto futuro
come abbiamo detto
torniamo alla storia spaziale l'origine
1500 vv
leggendario mandarino inventore cinese
perché è importante perché proprio lui
lui crea un veicolo una sedia una
piattaforma e 47 razzi a polvere pirica
chiese aiuto a 47 suoi addetti l'attacco
di attaccarli molto bene ma nessuno
capiva il significato ma nessuno sapeva
cosa effettivamente lui volesse fare lui
si sedette chiese aiuto per l'accensione
e prese il volo la leggenda narra che
dopo qualche metro ci fu poi veri di
fumo non si vede più lui nella la sedia
nella polvere pirica dei razzi
allora perché beatrice oggi vi racconta
di juan gual welt è ed è stato ed è
considerato il pioniere dell'aviazione
il primo è vero astronauta tanto che è
in onore suo è stato nominato un cratere
della luna cratere di juan
simpatico credere che in realtà one non
conosceva l'universo non conosceva la
luna lula vedeva diceva io voglio
arrivare a te
non conosceva neanche razzi sapeva solo
che poteva volare con essi
quindi tutto è partito da una sedia una
semplice sedia
oggi c'è chi crede che la terra è piatta
una linea dove inizia dove finisce e uno
da percorre
indefinita torna indietro ripercorre la
stessa strada un po come quando si guida
e c'è una strada chiusa e dice devo
tornare indietro uguale
alcuni può sembrare follia
peraltro in realtà questo io chiamo
punto di vista in base a come vedi sulla
terra
io oggi studio politica internazionale a
milano e nel mentre ho vinto una borsa
di studio in imprenditoria spaziale
dove insieme al 33 persone che in questo
momento sono situate in giro per il
mondo stati uniti in germania ed india
stiamo creando una startup spaziale sul
cyber security spaziale per meglio
intenderci a intelligence spaziale
magari alcuna domanda ma perché proprio
lo spazio con tutti i problemi che
abbiamo sulla terra guerre crisi
economiche crisi finanziare perché tra i
ragazzi quattro devono occupare il loro
tempo l'energia la voglia
lo spazio
bene noi stiamo cercando di creare il
nostro futuro che però
anche il vostro anche il nostro
che mio
il nostro obiettivo è cooperazione non
collaborazione attenzione la
cooperazione a un insieme un gruppo di
individui insieme che si mettono in
gruppo per raggiungere un solo e unico
obiettivo il nostro è quello di
migliorare la nostra terra per assurdo
anche se guardiamo al di fuori
dell'atmosfera
in questo momento esattamente in questo
momento sulla nostra testa stanno
lottando più di 5.000 satelliti intorno
di cui 1.500 sono americani di rete
quindi questi satelliti che hanno
scoperto il buco dell'ozono
monitora lo scioglimento dei ghiacciai
pensate che il satellite più importante
nello scioglimento dei ghiacciai e
italiano e uno di noi è nostro ma non è
da solo e insieme a mente di tutto il
mondo menti internazionale italiane
spagnole e francesi
americane
mediorientali russe tutti insieme
nessuna distinzione
e questi satelliti continuano il
monitoraggio della nostra terra
c'è un problema
questi satelliti molto spesso vengono
distrutti colpiti da detriti spaziali
spazzatura spaziale esatto
spazzatura spaziale da dove deriva la
spazzatura spaziale
deriva da noi
quando noi lanciamo un razzo sul
territorio terrestre
maggio prende il volo supera atmosfera è
certo punto
il motore che diciamo in fondo si stacca
si stacca perché ha già fatto il suo
dovere arrivato fino in fondo ha spinto
ha caricato il razzo non sarebbe più via
si lancia il razzo continua va avanti va
avanti c'è un altro pezzo non sarebbe
più altro motore viene lanciato e quindi
nell'atmosfera al di fuori
dell'atmosfera
iniziano rosari detriti
mila milioni miliardi triliardi di
attriti che continua a ruotare intorno a
noi e possono colpire un satellite
colpirlo satellite come colpire un
lavoro di menti in alimenti
internazionale di menti di tutto il
mondo
quindi
c'è una persona non è l'unica che sta
cercando di fare qualcosa di diverso
che sicuramente la conoscete elon musk
non è l'unico però insieme ad un gruppo
di persone grazie alla cooperazione
internazionale e spaziale sta cercando
di rendere il mondo
spaziale più sostenibile la
sostenibilità spaziale quante parole
spaziale spaziale
esatto lui ha creato un razzo che parte
da solo riatterra nello stesso posto e i
motori rimangono attaccati vengono
riutilizzati in continuazione per
evitare quindi che ci siano questi
detriti
elon musk e io lo vedo un po con un
extraterrestre
un po come
se lui non possono essere umano
l'obiettivo è quello di tornare a casa
sua a marte lo vedo un po così mi piace
pensarla così ma la realtà non lo è una
persona come noi come tutti noi tutte le
nostre storie
l'unica differenza è che lui ci crede
lui ha creduto di potercela fare
non sono i soldi non è la fama sa tutto
qua e non qui
quindi
facendo un passo indietro
alla domanda dei giovani spaziali chi
sono
per alcuni ora si può pensare che lo
spazio sia qualcosa di miccichè non
serve in realtà io vi dico che è il
futuro è il nostro futuro vostro mio di
tutti noi
la terra una culla ci ha fatto nascere
ci ha fatto crescere ed a cui mi ha
fatto anche morire
non ci sarà per sempre per me lo spazio
il mio presente e il mio futuro
quindi chi sono i giovani spaziali per
me i giovani spaziali siamo tutti adulti
i bambini anziani perché è il giovane
spaziale quello che si alza la mattina
con un solo obiettivo quello di cambiare
le cose di provarci di crederci e di non
mollare
perché anche se non è la giornata giusta
sicuramente si può fare qualcosa per
migliorare la giornata di qualcun altro
e non solo nell'ambito dello spazio
nell'ambito di qualsiasi cosa
quindi per me il giovane spaziale è
colui che fa un passo oltre al suo
comfort son
io ora mi siedo un po come quando si era
seduto sulla sua sedia
lui lui non sapeva la sua destinazione
lui non sapeva dove stava andando lui
non conosceva la sua meta aveva aveva
solo un sogno quello di
quello di provarci di mettercela tutta
a qualsiasi età
probabilmente vi diranno spesso che i
supereroi siamo tutti noi siamo siamo
dei grandi secondo me no secondo me
super eroe è colui che ci crede sempre
è colui che ai giovani dentro perché
l'età anagrafica non conta un bel niente
a un numero uno è giovane dentro sempre
quindi non molliamo mai superiamo sempre
la nostra comfort son crediamoci
lo spazio è molto vicino buona vita a
tutti giovani spaziali sognatori
[Applauso]